dans ce lycée c'est un enseignant qui a
été testé positif au coït 19 vendredi
dernier ils portaient un masque tout
comme les élèves face à lui qu'à
sensiblement différent dans cette école
maternelle c'est un enfants de petite
section qui a développé des symptômes
lundi alors qu'il venait de reprendre le
chemin de l'école
pas de masque bien sûr vu son jeune âge
mais un test positif également dans les
deux cas les patients ont été isolés les
parents d'élèves informés très content
que le calme mis en place elle nous a
prévenus très rapidement dans ce champ à
20 points
si le meilleur moyen de se protéger
d'avoir une action constructive
les élèves et les personnels qui ont été
en contact prolongé en classe avec ces
deux malades du coït 19 ont eux aussi
été mises en 14 n est fortement incitée
à se faire tester objectif rompre la
chaîne de contamination sans pour autant
fermer tout un établissement depuis le
11 mai et le retour d'une partie des
élèves en classe 4 cas de kovy de 19 ont
été détectés en bourgogne dans le milieu
scolaire
c'est un chiffre qui nous montre que le
site le virus circule toujours bien
évidemment mais que nous sommes en
capacité de prendre en charge ces
situations et de limiter la propagation
par les mesures de précaution les
mesures de prévention qui met tout en
place
y at il d'autres personnes contaminées
dans les deux établissements dits jeunes
est concerné par ces derniers cas
impossible pour l'heure de le savoir
les tests sur les personnes contacts ne
sont pratiqués qu'au bout de sept jours
période médiane d'incubation